explosive testimony to the january 6th
select committee this time from someone
who was inside the west wing that day
cassidy hutchison was a top aide to then
white house chief of staff mark meadows
she testified about the chaotic scenes
of president trump in fits of rage and
rejecting pleas from staff to tell
supporters to stand down as they attack
the capitol scott mcfarland is on
capitol hill with more from yesterday's
hearings scott good morning hey nate
good morning to you before yesterday
cassidy hutchinsons was a name and face
unfamiliar to many americans but her
testimony provided vivid details about
what the former president was doing the
days before and the days of the u.s
capitol attack and we have new
information this morning about one of
the most explosive allegations in her
testimony
in the days leading up to the capitol
riot former white house aide cassidy
hutchinson testified her boss chief of
staff mark meadows gave her this warning
there's a lot going on cass but i don't
know
things might get real real bad on
january 6. and on the morning of the 6th
hutchinson said then president trump was
warned people carrying weapons including
guns were descending on key landmarks in
d.c but that trumps ought to have the
metal detectors removed concerned
they've reduced the size of the crowd
for the rally at the white house ellipse
i overheard the president say something
to the effect of
you know i don't even care that they
have weapons
they're not here to hurt me take the
effing bags away
let my people in they can march the
capital from here hutchinson testified
trump also wanted to go to the capitol
which she described being told led to an
altercation in the presidential limo
when his chief secret service agent
bobby engel refused for security reasons
the president said something to the
effect of
i'm the effing president take me up to
the capitol now
to which bobby responded
sir
we have to go back to the west wing
the president
reached up towards the front of the
vehicle to grab at the steering wheel
mr engel grabbed his arm
said sir you need to take your hand off
the steering wheel
we're going back to the west wing we're
not going to the capitol
mr trump then used his free hand to
lunge towards bobby angle a source close
to the secret service tells cbs news
angle and the driver are prepared to
testify trump never lunged for the
steering wheel and that neither of them
were attacked
as rioters began their attack at the
capitol the president then refused to
take action hutchinson said she asked
meadows to intervene so we talked to the
president he said
no he wants to be alone right now amid
the riot she said white house counsel
pat cipoloni tried to prod meadows to
action too pat said something to the
effect of and very clearly
had
said this to mark something's the effect
of
mark something needs to be done or
people are going to die and the blood's
going to be on your effing hands she
testified meadows the white house
counsel and trump all knew of the chance
of hang mike pence echoing through the
mob
[Music]
i remember pat saying something to the
effect of
mark we need to do something more
they're literally calling for the vice
president to be effing hung
and mark had responded something to the
effect of
you heard him pat he thinks mike
deserves it hutchinson described her
disappointment by the president's tweet
writing mike pence didn't have the
courage
even as attackers poured onto the
capitol grounds as an american
i was disgusted
it was
unpatriotic it was
un-american as federal prosecutors watch
on former justice department official
harry lipman says hutchinson's testimony
added to the credible criminal case the
committee is building against trump he
not only knows about the violence but he
is fomenting it he wants to go to the
capitol and be the cheerleader of the
violence this put trump in the land of
seditious conspiracy
and inciting a riot former white house
eight also revealed meadows and rudy
giuliani sought presidential pardons
before trump left office an allegation
giuliani denies
at the end of the hearing vice chair liz
cheney detailed efforts by the former
president's inner circle to deter
witnesses from coming forward witness
tampering is of course a serious offense
to criminal prosecutors for his part
trump slammed the testimony calling it a
fake story and calling hutchinson
a phony
gayle
all right scott thank you very much